I'm a big nasty foot in your house guess
what if you day to clean me get crackin
okay oh oh I have a timer hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to ashy wash now this is a game
that was made in the game jam just
recently and it features this giant
disembodied floating foot that is
awfully bossy and telling me what to do
and as gross fungus on its toenails are
horrible and it's got flies floating
around and it's not attached to any sort
of body and I what is that is that rock
candy growing on the back ear he'll
opens candy Oh God so the idea is that
you're supposed to clean this and that's
it that's about the weirder spectrum of
games that I played but you know it's
not the weirdest I honestly can't say
what the weirdest is it might be murder
clown if you haven't seen murder clown
go see that one but this this you take
according to the gameplay that I saw
which I did not see much but I did see
you're supposed to have crap you're
supposed to take this spray can I swear
if you don't move any faster
I'm gonna turn your house into a pile of
dust the other body to go with that but
I guess I shouldn't question the giant
foot is this working we're just now
working hello there we go I gotta get
closer
so yeah the horrible fungus that's
growing on all the parts here friendly
neighborhood foot here sorry my brother
hurry up your schmuck I'm getting
impatient over here Oh wouldn't want you
to get impatient buddy but my brain is
still reeling from the fact that I'm
playing a game about cleaning and dices
and body foot that somehow is talking to
me if I go to the top there and get a
top-down perspective him I'm just gonna
see a weird disembodied mouth blabbering
away like an [ __ ] hope you do I do
this too is that what this do or is that
something else I'm not gonna get it in
time oh hello hi oh these are the same
textures as the walls did I mention that
this room made in a game jam I can only
assume no oh god that was it oh god no
oh no gross I mean for some people out
there this is probably an amazing game
and you all love it very much I'm not
gonna comment on anyone's personal brim
running out of time I don't know what
I'm doing
okay do I get to wash my eyeballs from
seeing these horrible things hey how do
I get that I want that I got a pic off
the rock can even Joey okay it's not not
click well [ __ ] too weak very poorly
I don't think I'm gonna win him then
he's gonna turn my house into dust okay
hang on I'll wait oh oh god that's some
crunch to that munch oh wow I can just
go right in the foot
oh no I can't nevermind look I'm still
filthy now we gotta smash your house up
the rules you made the rules oh you
could I'm a big nasty foot in your house
oh yeah that's amazing okay I'm gonna go
for the far one first
excuse my spit it's just the spit of
jubilation
I'm so happy then like my my career has
devoted to me playing a game
about me cleaning off a foot a giant
maniacal foot that wants to destroy my
house who invited him anyway I I failed
to mention that I have a certain number
of questions about this arrangement in
the first place oh good it's got
infinite replayability as much as you
want to clean this foot oh boy okay I
know it's in there I know it's in there
you're not gonna bug me on okay fine I'm
just gonna believe you on that one okay
that's fine at all
there we go okay so got that then we
just need this fungus it's a good thing
that I have exactly the supplies
required to be able to do all this
I'll get that fly just give me give me a
goddamn second to get up this the
gravity is not
ba-ba-ba-ba how do i hi
I'm doing the thing or and I oh oh there
we go that was a squish okay so almost
done
you're almost brimming pretty we're
almost prim and ready for the prom
you're pretty princess you got em toes
down here ya douche ya douche and
Scherbatsky come on caboose key what are
you not done you look done you're
running out of time you're so perfect oh
you're beautiful your big bulbous and
beautiful oh I love the way your art
goes oh I'm still filthy
no I gotta smash your house of weapons
the rules you're perfect just the way
you are how about you're a dick and I
hate you that's also options for things
that you are I'm getting impatient over
here running out of time yeah
oh god damn it he just closed right out
of there so there is the Hoshi wash what
an experience
a life-changing game if ever there was
one
I am weird and I feel dirty and I feel
odd but I'm done with that oh there you
go
you can see the other bizarre games I've
got quite a few I think that's actually
a playlist dedicated to in the
description below are the annotations
over there so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
oh why am i recording this I don't even
know